BRADY FORREST: Hi.
I'm Brady Forrest.
Welcome to Ignite.
We're going to have a fun
hour for you to cap off
your day here at Google IO.
It's going to be unlike any
other session that you were
in, in that is not
heavily scripted.
It is a bunch of people coming
together that share their
ideas and passions.
As mentioned, I'm
Brady Forrest.
I am with O'Reilly, and many,
many years ago, I start now
many years ago, I
started Ignite.
I also run Radar and do a
bunch of other conferences.
About 3 years ago, my friend,
Bre Pettis and I wanted
a geek event for our
friends in Seattle.
And we wanted a place where
they could share their thoughts
and passions, but very quickly.
Because not everybody
is that interesting!
And so, to do that, we set
some constraints around it.
But we wanted to make it a safe
place for them to do that.
We wanted to make it fun for
the audience and so all along
those lines, we invented
a torturous format.
And, we would ply the
speakers with beer.
We would ply the
audience with beer.
I apologize in advance.
We were unable to procure
any for this session.
But each speaker gets just 20
slides, 15 seconds a slide,
for a total of 5 minutes.
The speakers are not in control
of their slides entire time.
So, once they're up here, as
you've seen me do, they
kind of tap dance as their
slides change, and, in this
case, we have 10 talks.
We're going to be beginning
with Clay Johnson, learning
about the ins and outs of DC,
and we are going to be ending
with, "Where the Hell is
Matt?" And "A Great
Dance Around the World".
If you want to Tweet about it,
share your your thoughts on it,
look up information about this
later, use the hash
tag, Ignite IO.
I won't be checking Twitter
during this; I'll be too busy
hoping that Powerpoint doesn't
crash just so you know.
If you've never heard of
Ignite, Ignite's in over a
100 cities around the world.
It's spread far.
It's spread wide.
And if you want to throw
your own, just let me know.
There are thousands of
Ignite videos on line
at IgniteShow.com.
And it is super easy
and fun to start.
You really just need to borrow
a microphone and about 20
geeks, which I'm sure anyone
here could round up.
Now, I'd like to welcome
up our first speaker.
He is based in DC.
He's one of the people charged
with basically trying to
make our government
more transparent.
He does this through
Sunlight Labs.
Please welcome up their
CTO, Clay Johnson.
CLAY JOHNSON: How
are you guys doing?
No, no, no no!
Come on!
This is Ignite!
That's what I'm talking about!
00:03:21,358 --> 00:03:21,278
I'm Clay Johnson.
I direct Sunlight Lab at
the Sunlight Foundation.
My primary job is
fighting Zombies.
I fight Zombies in Washington
DC, where a lot of
them get created.
And we work with
government data.
And I need your help to
fight these Zombies too.
Zombies, for the most part,
are being generated by bad
information and bad access
to information, generally
by people like this.
This is Glenn Beck and he
is a Zombie producer.
Also Keith Olbermann, in the
interest of partisanship,
is also a Zombie producer.
And other people who produce
really commercial information.
It's like commercially
process food.
This is Tyson's Any'Tizers.
They're Dippin' Twists.
Good for any time.
And I don't know what the fuck
they're made out of, man!
And it's the same thing
with information.
If you think about it
information and food
are pretty similar.
They have these food
chains, right?
So food goes from organic
matter to vegetables, meats, to
people, and facts go data, to
wire services, to bloggers
and distributors, people.
At the top of both of these
food chains are Zombies!
And that's what we have to fix.
So what I do is,
I fight Zombies.
What we do, is we get
data out of government
to empower people.
Now here's a good example of
some Zombies; Don't Steal
from Medicare to Support
Socialized Medicine.
It's the equivalent of
people saying "Brains.
Brains" So, we
take this data, right?
This is every campaign
contribution, not every one,
but this is a cobalt base file
of every campaign contribution
that every member of
Congress has ever received.
And we make it so that people
can easily say, that hey, maybe
our health care system is
messed up because of campaign
contributions and lobbyists
and stuff like that, right?
So, this is
TransparencyData.com where you
can easily get all of the
Nelson's campaign contributions
at the State or Federal of
level over the past 30 years
and you can get API.
You can do cool things with the
it, like integrate it with
Gmail, so you can see
who is contributing.
It does a look up for the
sender of the email.
It also checks for lobbyists,
so you can be aware registered
federal lobbyists
that email you.
So, in 4000BC, writing
was a trade secret of
a professional scribe.
It was locked up and
not given to people.
And, I think something
interesting has changed now.
Instead of writing, it's truth
that's a trade secret of
professional scribes.
And, it's up to developers to
really bust down that barrier,
because we have the power to
change Washington, DC through
giving people better
access to the truth.
Now these are currently
truth-tellers.
They're called
"Bloggers" Well, on
the left you have a Blogger,
next the Blogger, and Social
Media Expert and, then you have
a Marketing Consultant and some
dude who got poisoned with LSD
or something like that.
But developers can tell
the truth through code.
They can start using data to
give people better access to
the truth and build tools like
for transparency data or tools
on top of transparency data
to give people access the
sane, rational thought.
You go to this web site here,
the National Data Catalog, and
say hey, maybe a mine exploded
and you wanted to see the mine
safety records of all
of the United States.
You can get that data right
here and start saying, hey
maybe Massey Energy isn't doing
well by its employees, and
is killing its employees.
You can do the same thing with,
say there's an oil spill.
You can see where people are
getting their oil from, and
how much foreign oil we
are actually dependent on.
Then you can start tying
all this data together.
This is a web site that one of
our grantees built called
LittleSis.com that allows
people to tie alll this data
together, and build profiles.
It's a mandatory Facebook
of influential people.
It's pretty awesome.
So.
That's a Zombie.
So these tools help you fight
these people, and make it so
that your arms don't get
chewed off by a pretty,
blue eyed Zombie.
So, one last thing, fighting
Zombies makes you money.
GPS, weather, all kinds of
data initiatives coming from
government have created massive
economies, massive industries,
and this isn't just a social
cause, it's something much
more significant than that.
So, thank you very much.
You guys have been great!
Let's hear it for Brady.
00:08:11,998 --> 00:08:11,698
BRADY FORREST: And thank
you very much, Clay.
And now we're going to
move away from DC.
All the way back to Mountain
Dew, and Seattle with the
former Googler, the woman
behind the original
Web Master Central.
Please welcome up Vanessa
Fox, a seeker of truth.
VANESSA FOX: Okay.
Thank you, Brady.
So, normally, we have these
things in a pub, and you're
all drunk and its awesome,
and I'm so much better.
But, so, since we're not in a
pub today, we're going to find
out the meaning of life.
I checked Google first.
The meaning of life, of course,
they say it's 42, which used to
be really awesome, but now with
the movie coming out, a
few years ago, everyone
knows the answer is 42.
If you do the Flicker search,
you see that it's old hat.
So, we're not cool anymore
to really know anymore
the answer 42.
But they also think the
meaning of life is Google,
so that scared me.
So, I thought that I would look
for the meaning of life on
Bing, because that's
the decision engine.
00:09:05,526 --> 00:09:05,3
Sorry Google.
They told me I should look for
what's my dragon name, which
lead me to a site to find a
dragon name for my dog,
horse, cat or child.
That was very disturbing.
I thought, perhaps that I
instead, I would try Yahoo,
another search engine.
It told me to find the
meaning of life on these
3 places, in this order.
And, the bible is the only one
in lower case which I didn't
know exactly what that meant.
So I went to Twitter first
and it actually pointed
me to Facebook.
And so, I thought, okay.
And the meaning of life is
Robert Pattinson looks like
a foot, of Twilight fame.
I didn't think this was really
leading me in the direction
I had been looking for.
So, I thought I'd do another
search on Facebook, What's
the meaning of Life?
It told me to YouTube,
back to Google, right?
The number 2 engine is YouTube.
This is what YouTube said that
the meaning of life was.
This is actually disturbed me
maybe just as much as Robert
Patterson looks like a foot.
So, I didn't learn the meaning
of life, but what I did
learn was that people are
crazy on the internet.
And, I was like, OK, maybe
I'm just looking at
the wrong thing.
Maybe I just really need
to know why are people on
the internet so crazy?
So, this is the next
search that I did.
And, what I found
was that this.
I do research a serious subject
and what I found find is that
the author would like to shoot
the pope, or would like to do
strange things to my
unmentionable parts.
And also, by the way, why
do all the crazy people
use the caps button?
And these things seem to be an
equal interest to this person.
So, I thought, well,
that's a good question?
So, why do all crazy people
use caps on the internet?
And what I found was, does
anyone have a good recipe
for a red velvet cake.
And, I was like, yeah,
dude I love cake.
I ended on this site, which
with a bunch of people in a
flame war about whether the
Star Trek characters should
really be on the cake because
really, was he a navigator?
And ended up with this guy
saying, have you kissed a girl?
Turn off caps-lock
on your computer.
So I thought I'm going to
really go to the root of crazy
people and ask them what the
meaning of life is, which of
course, lead me ChatRoulette.
Then, I looked into
Chatroulette, and I was
like, you know, I'm
not going after all.
I don't need know the
meaning of life that bad.
So, instead that validated that
people on the internet or crazy
but also the other thing, of
course, is that we
all search, right?
You've all been searching,
and you found that people
wanted to things to your
unmentionable parts.
So, we do 2.9 million
searches a minute.
We use major search engines for
everything. 71% of us use major
search engines for looking
for health information.
So, life or death.
Are we going to live?
Are we going to die?
And we're doing searches with
all of those crazy people on
ChatRoulette, and this is how
we're getting our information.
The same is true with
government information.
A study just found that search
engines was how we get our
government data that apparently
cause us to be Zombies, so
that that's a bit scary.
We used to use the library to
get information, but it turns
out that the days, that only
13% of people use the library
as that place to find
information. 58% use it to look
for reference books, but except
that 65% use it to go on the
internet where all the
crazy people are.
So there is a Slate article
that talked about this.
That we really like to seek and
search, and when we do that, it
causes the chemicals in our
brain to mimic the state that
we're in when we're on cocaine.
And so that causes us just to
keep searching more and more.
Sort of, that's how I ended up
seeing that cat crazy guy.
So apparently when you search,
this is what happens.
So this is kind of
article ended.
If humans seeking machines,
we've created the perfect
machines to allow us
to seek endlessly.
So, what does that mean, right?
So some other experts have
looked it, and said, OK we
don't get really good search
results, but the reason we
don't, is because most of the
queries we do are
a single word.
So its our own fault.
It's all you guy's fault that
you ended up at the crazy
people, because you just didn't
know how to search correctly.
Some other people are
like, well, maybe
that's not the problem.
Maybe it's just that there's so
much information out there.
There's not a good way to
catalog it, and we think
if it's popular or in the
top 10 search results,
it must be accurate.
Which isn't true.
So what should we do with this?
So, I would say this.
When we search, its like
we're on drugs, so therefore
we're not going to stop.
We're going to keep
doing it more and more.
And yet, what we're ending up
with is a world full of crazy
people so what does that mean
for the future of how we
interact with information?
Thank you.
BRADY FORREST: And we're lucky
to have our next speaker here,
because he was almost eaten
over the North Atlantic.
Please welcome Bradley Vickers.
BRADLEY VICKERS: I'm going to
talk about rowing across the
North Atlantic ocean from New
York to Thalamus, England.
It's a journey of about
3200 nautical miles.
And, I completed it
in about 71 days.
Just over 71 days with
my 3 other teammates.
And we recognize by Guinness
World Records as having had the
first landfall to landfall
crossing of the North
Atlantic ocean.
I think that you can take some
hopefully observations from
this crossing and apply to
whatever projects you guys
might be involved with.
The actual expedition took
about 18 months to prepare for.
And part of that was
getting our team together.
The 4 of us had rowed
together in college, and
we figured, why not?
Let's row across an ocean.
We also had to outfit our 28 by
6 foot ocean rowboat with a
solar panel and that fueled our
communications and our
navigation systems and it also
powered our desalinator, which
converted salt water
into fresh water.
Now the actual crossing
is both the mental and
physical challenge.
As you can see from the slide
behind me, the transformation
both physically and
mentally that I underwent.
That last one, I'm loosin' it!
Get me to shore!
Part of the physical nature of
this, is we were rowing in
shifts of 2 hours. 2 hours on,
2 hours off. 2 on, 2 off, 2 on,
2 off. 24 hours a day,
someone's at the oars
for 12 of those.
So we're continually
sleep-deprived.
You see Jordan there, in the
corner, sleeping were 1
eye open in the cabin.
It's a very cramped cabin.
It's about 8 foot by 5 foot, so
you never getting full rest.
You're also having to keep
yourself clean and your
clothing, because you don't
want to get salt waters sores.
And we were downloading
satellite images of the North
Atlantic and weather reports
and uploading our blog via
Iridium satellite phone.
So we need to the eat
during our 2 hours off.
And we had budgeted between 8,
sorry 7 and 8,000 calories
per rower per day.
It was an immense
amount of food.
I was in charge of planning the
food, and I miscalculated.
Which is not a fun thing
to tell your teammates.
I realize it on day 14 and it
took me until day 17 that I
worked up the courage
to tell my teammates.
We would lose a
combined 137 pounds.
I lost 28, Dylan 32, Jordan,
35 and Greg, 42 pounds!
Now, ultimately we were
successful in achieving our
goal which was rowing across
the North Atlantic without
physical assistance, so we
couldn't be resupplied by food.
We achieved that, and I think
the outlook that we had and the
process we went through can be
applied to getting through
challenging settings with a
group of people in
a team dynamic.
We were on a 29 by 6 foot boat
and we couldn't get off, so
we had to work together.
One of the ways that we
work together is we had
conversations for the boat, and
we had conversation for land.
If it was constructive,
if it was productive,
it was for the boat.
If it was destructive, or if
we are trying to find out
whose fault it was, mainly
mine, it was for land.
Hopefully, over a large a
warm meal and multiple
cold beverages!
So we kept ourselves focused on
solution based suggestions.
The other thing is our process.
Immediately upon realizing that
we were short on food, we
inventoried the entire boat, so
we could start dealing with
some facts and numbers and we
realized if we rationed, we
could make it to England.
So we had a plan.
And we had that plan, we had
something to focus our efforts
and our energies towards,
rather than bickering amongst
ourselves, and we made
progress towards our goal.
And with that plan, we
learned more information.
We learned how we responded
the low calorie intake.
And we constantly readjusted
our plan, but our goal
remained constant.
And I think that's huge when
you're working on a project.
Don't shift your goal to
meet the settings that
you find yourself in.
Constantly adjust your plan and
your own actions that you're
taking to achieve that goal.
I've really enjoyed sharing my
experience with all of you and
I hope that you're able to take
these stories and apply them to
whatever pursuits that you're
in and whether personal,
professional, whatever passions
they are, I wish you the best
of luck in achieving
your own adventures.
Thank you.
00:19:10,76 --> 00:19:10,1
[APPLAUSE]
BRADY FORREST: Thank you
very much, Bradley.
As I mentioned, there are
Ignites around the world.
And we're lucky to have the
organizer of the Community
Leadership Summit Ignite here.
He does a lot of work with
helping people get together
communities build communities
and keep them together.
He's here to share
some secrets.
Please welcome Van Riper.
VAN RIPER: Just to be clear,
I'm not a Communities
Serial Organizer.
Not that there's anything wrong
with that, but, I'm here
talking today about my work as
a Serial Community Organizer.
I know, bad joke.
You're supposed to be drinking.
These are some of
my communities.
The bird is Juggie.
The JUG's mascot.
JUG stands for Java User
Groups, probably not what
some of you were thinking.
I did create this Yahoo
group for a production
of Hello Dolly.
The theater director of my
daughter's show did say to
me, so, I see, you are
a community organizer.
Shortly after that, my
career as a community
organizer really began.
At BayChi, I helped others
organize their own small
communities for more
than a decade.
I also learned the importance
of regular, in person meetings
to build communities.
Oh, yeah, the lady in the
lower left, she's taken.
She's my wife's,
Mary Von Riper.
The Silicon Valley web
job that was the first
community that I started.
I escaped the imploding
start up world for a
safe haven at Verisign.
The pay was good, but
the legacy code work
was killing me.
For fun, I would hang
out with other Java
Developers at my JUG.
Java, Java, Java,
Javajava jing jing jing.
These folks are my Java possie,
in particular Aaron Houston, in
baseball cap, played a pivotal
role in my efforts as a
community organizer with
the JUGS and the Java
champions communities.
In 2006, I came close
to burning out.
If Kevin had not come along --
Are you here, Kevin?-- All
right, if you had not come
along and played Robin to my
Batman who knows what
would have happened?
But it quickly evolved into
a relationship of equals.
These global maps are all
created by me in KML.
And maps that's like these
are a great way to support
a global community.
One of these is not like the
others, and you'll have
to ask Brady why that is.
So, it's kind of like code
camp, its a free annual event
by developers, for developers.
That lunch line had 1,000
hungry developers in it.
We gave of almost 200 large
pizzas that day, and its
already open for registration.
This shirt is showing the tag
cloud of the most recent code
camp, and Peter Kellner and
Tammy Baker are the original
organizers, and I
help them now.
You can see how Java has become
a big part of last year's camp.
Chris Shaw is actually behind
the start of the Google
technologies user groups.
And, we had our first
meeting in January, 2008.
Stephanie Lou and Jason Cooper
are our current sponsors and
look for the GTUG camp
out this summer.
But whether you're looking for
a GTUG near you, or you want to
start a new group, you should
come check out the
GTUG lounge here.
That's where you'll find
people like me hang
out during the break.
And please do visit
GTUGS.org on line.
Organizing developer
communities is fun, but I
needed something more.
I attended the first leadership
summit in the summer of 2009.
I was swimming in as the sea
of community organizers.
That event was a natural
high for someone like me.
Jono Bacon, , the author
of "The Art Of
Community" organized
the first CLS.
He believes in building family
values in your communities
through events.
With Marcy Hennin egging me on,
I decided to put this into
practice, organizing the
first regional CLS event.
Thus, CLS West in January,
2010 came to pass.
Irene Koehler found
us a great venue.
Dave Neilsen and Sudha
Jamthe were our fundraisers
extraordinaire.
Colea did her magic running the
conference, Sonya Barry did an
amazing job handling the food.
Its hard to believe, but the
second edition of the main CLS
event is only 2 months away and
I've been asked to
help organize it.
I've somehow become
the organizer of
community organizer.
If you do community work,
you have to be there.
I was a map volunteer
for Global Ignite Week.
It inspired me to plan
something similar for the
CLS movement in 2011.
On this stage, I'm officially
announcing plans for a regional
month next January, And
you could be a part of it.
See me to find out.
People often ask how I can put
so much effort into these
volunteer activities.
I did start out to
scratch my own itch.
But, I soon found it
was enriching my life.
Brian Sharp has some concrete
practices that'll make you a
better leader and
a better person.
Google has some great
community technologies.
But technology doesn't
build communities.
People build communities.
Spend time getting to
know people here.
Don't just soak up the
technology, even for geeks like
us, it's still about the people
whose lives we have touched.
I like fortune cookies.
Next time you open one, add
in community leadership to
the end of your fortune.
It's not as a titillating as
the traditional game, but you
might be surprised
by the results.
That's all, folks.
BRADY FORREST: Thank
you very much, Van.
Yeah I met Van when he
was helping out with
Globaal Ignite week.
Thanks again.
Our next speaker, I met
just two weeks ago?
A week and a half ago?
She is on a Knight Ridder
scholarship to research
journalism, and she's trying to
learn how to tell stories
through locative media, and it
seemed to me that the home of
Google Maps might just be the
perfect place for her
to tell her story.
Please welcome for
Chrissy Clark.
CHRISSY CLARK: Hello, my name's
Chrissy Clark, and and I make
documentaries for public radio,
but don't worry, I'm not going
to ask you for money right now.
I'm going to tell you
about a vision that
I had in the desert.
But to understand that
vision, you need to know
a little bit about me.
I am a fifth generation
Californian.
My great-great grandfather came
to the bay area in 1848 on a
mule, and the legacy of that is
it that as a kid when I was
growing up I heard a lot of
stories from my dad about the
world that I was driving
through all the time.
So, he would point at things
and he would say that
used to be that.
That industrial wind farm
used to be our family's
general store.
Or, that big, 8 lane freeway
that goes out onto the Golden
Gate bridge, that you
see to be was my dad's
personal jungle gym.
He claims to have climbed
it that when the bridge
was under construction.
I don't know if I believe that.
But what I did learn through
all of that was that a
landscape is made
out of stories.
It's sort of the layers and
layers of stories like the
geologic strata, and that
is what inspired me to
become a radio reporter.
I started moving around the
world and asking questions
about how places got to be
the way that they were.
So one of those questions
was it bad neighborhoods.
We've all been through bad
neighborhoods or avoided them.
Why are they the
way that they are?
How did they get
to be that way?
I asked that question about a
neighborhood in San Francisco
in the western addition.
And it turns out that
neighborhood was not always
a bad neighborhood.
In fact, it used to be in the
1940's a cultural mecca for the
African-American community.
It was called the
Harlem of the West.
But in the 1960's it was a
target for urban redevelopment
and so there were at 13,000
families been were moved out of
San Francisco a lot of
buildings were raised
and, voila, you get
a bad neighborhood.
Another question I started
asking about the landscape
in San Francisco was,
why is this city gay?
Why of all of the cities in the
world, is San Francisco gay?
And so it actually has a lot to
do with this building up here,
which is 710 Montgomery Street.
It's now kind of a yuppy
restaurant, but in the 1940's,
it was a cafe called The Black
Cat Cafe and a guy named Jose
Sarria would come and dance in
drag, these lovely black
evening gowns and sing songs
about his life as a
homosexual male.
They were flamboyant and funny
and provocative and political
and people started
flocking to them.
And the reason that he didn't
get kicked out of that bar, as
he would of in most other parts
of the country at that time is
that San Francisco, it wasn't
that it was so liberal, but is
actually it was a loophole in a
post prohibition way that
bars as are regulated.
In most parts of that country,
bars the regulated by a
morality police, or
were back then.
But in San Francisco bars were
regulated by tax collectors and
so they just wanted
to get money.
They didn't care what was going
on in on, and, voila, the
gay rights movement was
born in San Francisco.
So these sorts of stories were
on my mind as I was driving
through a desert in Utah a
couple of years ago and I saw
this cabin and had this urge I
wanted to know the stories
about this cabin, because I
was in the middle of nowhere.
Why the hell was cabin here?
And I wanted the click on
that cabin, like you would
click on a hyper-link.
Maybe I'd had been in front of
a computer for too long and I
know that was a delirious
idea back then.
But, as you know it is not a
delirious idea anymore, thanks
too many of you in this room.
You can click on the world.
You can click on the world,
and get information.
So, if we're driving through
the Utah desert, right now, and
we clicked on this cabinet,
what kind of information
would we get?
Well, we'd get some cool
Wikipedia articles.
We'd be told that it is
it desert, which we
kind of all ready knew.
We would also get some Yelp
restaurant reviewes maybe.
Some other bits of sorts
of drips and drabs
from the internet.
And that stuff is amazing.
Mind blowing.
My great-great-grandfather
would be amazed.
But one of the things that we
aren't getting yet is stories.
The personal dramas, the
economic policies, the
environmental issues, the
political struggle that make a
place what it is and shapes the
people who live there.
It's sort of getting the
meaning onto the landscape.
And as a journalist those are
the sorts of stories that I
tell all of the time and
they're actually thousands and
thousands of archives of those
sorts of stories that are
locked up right now and don't
really have a home
out in the world.
And so, what I'm interested in
doing is getting those stories,
those archives on to the world
so that we can click on them.
So, say we're driving through
Utah, we see that cabin, maybe
we click on it and we find out,
and it's true, I researched it,
that it cabin happens to be as
desolate as it is in the one of
the counties that have the
highest in job growth in the
country over the last 10 years.
Or we find out that it was a
place where a radioactive waste
facility is about to be built.
So its those sorts of stories
not just in Utah but all over
the country, all over the world
that I'm interested and putting
onto the landscape and if
you want to talk to me
about that, please do.
My email is there,
you can click on me.
Thanks.
BRADY FORREST: She didn't know
what Ignite was a week ago.
Thank you very much.
Our next speaker is a digital
artist, and I think it's best
just to say he makes beautiful
things through code.
00:30:40,4 --> 00:30:40,3
Please welcome up Aaron Koblin.
AARON KOBLIN: Thanks.
So, in addition to being a
technology lead at Google's
creative labs, I also have a
passion for making art with
with large data sets and
large groups of people
on the internet.
So I'm going to try to breeze
through really quickly a few
projects I have been
working on recently.
Particularly crowd
sourcing projects.
Some of you may be
familiar with this.
Barron Wolfgang von
Kempelen mechanical
chess playing machine.
This is actually a robotic
chess player, except for the
fact that it's not at all.
There's a leg-less guy who sits
a box and he controls this
thing, acting like
he's machine.
I thought this was a
particularly bizarre story,
especially because Amazon
created a web service based off
this that some of you may be
familiar, with called The
Mechanical Turk, and it uses
the premise that there's
certain things that are easy
for people but hard
for machines.
And now can farm out
these tasks to a large
number of people.
And they can do these little
things in complete isolation
from one another.
And they call it artificial,
artificial intelligence.
So it's a really weird concept.
There's like thousands of
people, and none of them have
any idea what they're doing
but you can ask them
to do anything.
So I thought what can I do
and how can experiment
with the system?
I decide to make a first
project where I asked them to
draw sheep facing to the left.
And I said I'll pay you
$0.02 for this task.
And, it's a very simple drawing
tool that has a side slider and
a gray slider and you can start
drawing away at your sheep.
And I started collecting sheep,
a large number of sheep.
These are a few of sheep
that I collected.
You can see kind of a really
interesting juxtaposition.
You have this very mechanized
huge system and all
these individuals.
I also captured the
drawing process of
each individual sheep.
I am going to rattle
off a bunch of URLs.
Hopefully maybe some you will
get to check them later.
TheSheepMarket.com you can see
where where all these sheep
were drawn and you can actually
purchased them, which is
another interesting topic.
I don't know if I have time
to get into in the Ignite.
But, you can browse
through the all.
See them all here's some stats
for the project: There's
about 11 sheep per hour were
coming in over 40 days.
There were 662 sheep that
didn't meet "sheep like
criteria" [LAUGHTER]
and were through
out of the mix.
There were 7,599 unique IP
addresses, so that you
an idea about how many
people participated.
But only one of
them asked this!
It's a really valid question,
and I really expect
a lot more that.
There's a lot of reasons that
people drawing sheep, reference
to cloning, reference to labor,
I don't have time
to get into it.
This is another project.
I took a frame Charlie
Chaplin's Modern Times.
On the left side, you have
the frame then divided
into 16 pieces.
Individual people drawing
different portions for $0.05.
Amazing dedication that
was going to these tasks.
And this is a sample from a
project that I worked on
with my friend, Takashi
Kawashima, which was based
on this notion where you give
somebody something and they
recreate what they see without
knowing what it is that
they're working on.
We decided to take it quite
literally what the mechanical
turk was used for,
making money.
And we created a
hundred dollar bill.
We pay the workers the literal
values their contribution, so
that's $0.01 for 10,000 people
maybe making this
00:33:39,924 --> 00:33:39,778
massive forgery.
What you see here is
everybody's contributions.
If they drew a smiley
face, its in there.
There if they actually drew
what they where asked to do
it's also there so you can
get a sense of what's going.
I really don't have time to
talk about this one, but if you
get a chance, Bicyclebuiltfor
2000.com is the audio
version of this.
I worked with my friend Daniel
Massey, and we collected sound
samples and did a granular
synthisism of the sound bicycle
built for 2000 where can hear
individual people making tones
and emulating tones
to make the song.
Another audio based project
that I got to work on - I got
to work with Radiohead, one of
my favorite bands, and director
James Frost, and we shot
this video using laser
scanners as 3D data.
We made music video
without video.
We were looking at it
as time [INAUDIBLE]
space.
We basically then released it
as an open source project on
Google Code, and we allow
people to download some source
code to play with the data and
also the data itself, and
people started making
their own versions.
This probably my favorite
part of this project.
The fact that it really start
to create a community of people
making interesting content.
And you see here on the bottom
left, the pin board version
of the of Tom York singing.
There's a Lego version.
In the center, there's someone
who actually 3D printed Tom
York's face so now, there's
this physical manifestation
of it as well.
I thought this was
really exciting.
That there were people working
together and they knew
what they were doing.
And I thought, let's do
something like that.
That led to this project,
Johnny Cash Project,
which we just launched.
This is Johnny Cash's last
album, making music video for
the song "Ain't No Grave
Can Hold My Body Down" and
we're actually kind of
resurrecting, director Chris
Milk and I ressurecting Johnny
Cash through individual
users drawings.
So you can see here none
of these are photographs.
They are hand drawn frames that
people can contribute to make
this music video that's
constantly changing.
So it's not a single video.
There's actually different
tracks and different community
around it rating and judging.
This is Gray Area Foundation
for the Arts and I
wanted a quick call out.
Here in San Francisco we have
workshops that basically lead
different types of thinkers to
use programming and other tools
and get artists and designers
and other people kind of using
technology to interesting ways.
One of things we talk about a
lot is this to tool called
processing which basically a
series of libraries in Java
which makes it really easy for
artists and designers and
people aren't necessarily
familiar with Java which
or programming to start
doing creative coding.
I highly recommend that
you check it out.
Finally, last but definately
not least, I want to mention
Chrome Experiments which is a
website I helped launch at
Google, which is showing a
bunch of the really interesting
HTML5 and Javascript hacks and
demos, some stuff you may have
not realized you could
do in a browser.
And since you are all
developers, I'd love for you
to check it out and also
contributed if you
get a chance.
Thanks very much.
BRADY FORREST:
Thank you, Aaron.
Who loved to the animation
behind the speaker's
this morning?
With the wires that
create Google?
You can thank him
for that as well!
And, his team, and his team.
Now as you may guess,
we're about to talk about
someone else's hobby.
The physical manifestation
of You Sunk My Battleship.
Please welcome James Young!
00:36:35,88 --> 00:36:35,1
JAMES YOUNG: Thank you.
Model warship combat is taking
World War 1, World War 2
battleships and building 1/42
scale models of them, arming
them with working BB guns and
going to a pond and just
the shooting the crap
out of each other.
It's a game, a game we play,
and like all games, it's got
rules and everybody has
to obey the rules for
the game to be fun.
These are the rules for the
various formats and like Mac
versus Linux versus Windows.
You take your pick, and you
stick with your religion.
Big Gun is, in my
opinion, the most fun.
You have 1/4 ball bearings.
You fire everything, you man
everything, you do everything
as much to scale as
you possibly can.
And that's what
these boats are.
The guns can be really complex,
from rotating to pressing
turrets, to really simple guns
that fire fast as
you possibly can.
And they are all C02 powered.
They run quite well.
You're going to start
with original ships.
They have to be ships that were
really lay down or built in
World War 1, World War 2.
This is the Cleveland
in that corner.
This is the Rodney from the UK.
You're going to learn about the
people that served on, and it's
really fascinating to find out
the history of the ships.
And you can pick whatever kind
of ship you want, aircraft
carrier, submarine.
Battleships are the
easiest to do.
You've got the most
space, the most room.
There's room to work with.
There's room to put all of your
guns and do everything that
you want to do with it.
You can find plans on line.
A lot of people in the hobby
make plans for these ships, or
you can go straight to the
Library of Congress, get the
original plans from the Navy,
scale them down to 1/44 scale
and build it yourself.
You can buy fiberglass wholes
on line, or you are good with
wood working skills, you
can make it yourself.
You're kind of making a
framework to lay a thin layer
of balsa wood around the ship,
and that balsa wood is
what you're shooting.
And how it sinks
and takes damage.
You can go really detailed.
This is a fine example.
This is the Yamoto here on the
right, or you can you can be
really simple like mine, and
like the other one up there.
It really depends on how much
time and skill that you
have to dedicate a hobby.
And it it's really
about money and time.
People say how much does it
cost, and I'm like, well,
anywhere from about
$500 to $2000.
It really just depends on how
much skill you can put in the
one and how much is you ust
want to buy from somebody else
that's done the work for you.
Once you've got your ship, once
its all ready, you go to the
pond, you put it on the
pond with everyone else,
and you have battles.
And they usually have an
objective so the access team
has to get their transports
across the pond and back across
the pond without sinking and
the allies have to accomplished
some goal without being
destroyed, maybe it's just a
death match style battle and
everybody just goes out there,
and everybody tries to sink
everybody else, and the last
man on the top of the
pond wins the game.
But they're really
shooting BBs.
They're really doing damage to
each other, so stuff's going
to get shot off your ship.
You're going to have
holes punched in the
side of your ship.
You've got bilge pumps.
You can see the spray on that
one up there, the where the
bildge pump is spraying up and
you're going to sink, and
it's part of the game.
Everybody sinks, it kind of
sucks, but, that's what you are
there for, is to what you're
out there for, is to
sink and be sunk.
So the ships are all
designed, you waterproof
as much as you can.
You've got protection around
your electronics, so you
just pull your boat
out of the water.
You patch the holes on it.
And, 15 minutes later you ready
to fight another battle.
The kind of damage you can
take can be pretty severe.
I've got some pictures
right there of the
damage that you'll take.
It's not small.
You're really getting your
boat shot to pieces.
And so to repair it, you can
either put masking tape over
it for a temporary repair.
There's a really thin cloth
that impregnated with glue
that you can put on there.
And in the wintertime when the
when the ponds are all frozen
over, you ust peel off your
balsa wood and put new
balsa wood on there.
There are clubs that do this
all over the world, from
Australia to England and
in the United States.
There's clubs in almost every
region of the of the country.
I am from Utah, and
I'm a Navy of one.
00:41:06,858 --> 00:41:06,498
It's just me.
So if anybody here from
Utah then give me a call,
and I'll bring you out.
Who's here from the bay area?
Give me a shout.
OK, these are your people.
These guys are in San Jose
and they're from all
around the bay area.
And we'll be at Makers Fair
this weekend and we'll have a
huge battle at Maker's Fair.
RC Naval Combat is the
place you want to go.
This is where we all talk
on line and this is
my contact info.
I love to talk
about this hobby.
I have to say thank you to my
wife and to my best friend
Sam [? Rosskelly ?]
00:41:38,538 --> 00:41:38,158
who made this hobby possible.
Thank you very much.
BRADY FORREST: James, we
normally don't have time
for questions, but
I just have to ask.
How many eyes do
you lose a year?
Thank you.
Our next speaker has been
experimenting with Wave from
the beginning and has made
homage to what I can only
assume is Buffy the Vampire
Slayer with ElizaBot.
Please welcome Anne Veling.
Anne Veling I'd like to share
with you a little adventure
I've had with Google Wave
over the past year.
Let me ask you a question.
Who was here at IO last year.
It was great.
I was here to and I was
excited to meet so many smart
people just like today.
I was also excited to hear
about Google Wave, and even
though a year later Google Wave
may not have been the overnight
success that we've may
have hoped, I feel strongly
believe in the vision behind
Google Wave, because instead of
us juggling around the objects
between the people who need to
collaborate and sending it back
and forth, Google Wave,
actually turns that model
upside down and as all these
people collaborate and go
towards the wave, and
move toward the object
collborate on that.
I also like wave because of the
protocol well so technology.
And as I'm a nerd, what's
the best way to find out?
Actual programming.
So when I came home last
year, that's what I did.
I thought, lets create a Google
Wave robot and as I have a
background in artificial
intelligence.
I thought let's create Eliza.
L Eliza, it was created by
Professor Weizenbaum in 1966 as
a simple pattern recognition
script that looks for certain
words in your what you are
typing, juggles them around and
creates questions back just
like to shrink would do.
Only a shrink would charge you
money, and Eliza's for free.
I looked up on the internet got
an open source Eliza script and
00:43:44,178 --> 00:43:44,158
played around with it
just a week after IO.
I used Google Wave Robot API,
app engine, App engine,
which I'd never used before
and I used this Eliza.
Grouped it all together.
Two hours later, I had
this Elizabot just for
myself and it worked.
I was happy.
This is her name
ElizaRobot@Appsbot.com Feel
free to use her and you
can confide in her.
She has a doctor-patient
confidentiality so she
has nothing to say.
So, I chatted with her.
Had fun.
00:44:14,826 --> 00:44:14,798
Learned a lot about
Google Wave.
00:44:17,82 --> 00:44:17,698
Had fun.
Learned a lot about Wave and
blogged about it and I thought
that's where the story ended.
To
my big surprise what happened
is she got enormous
amount of attention.
I believe I was the first
person outside Google to
create a Google Wave robot.
And a lot of people would start
chatting with her, inviting
me to Waves with her.
There's YouTube fan
videos of her.
It's amazing.
But, as always there's
also a dark side.
Because, what would happen is
that one person, one funny
guy would add Eliza
to a public wave.
And because of the scalability
of app engine and Google Wave
robot, all of these Eliza's
would respond to everybody at
the same time immediately.
It was amazing.
And remember in those days,
you could not throw somebody
out of a Wave, right?
So Google have to create
Bouncy, which had special
privileges to kick
somebody out.
And, it's only since last
month, that in Google Wave,
you can actually remove a
participant from a Wave.
I can understand that because,
it's not just about technology,
its about what do you want?
How do you want it to work?
And who is allowed
to restrict access?
And why?
What happens to the state
of the the person, what
he's already seen?
And all of those functional
aspects are important.
And, how do you even know who
he is a roobot, and who is not?
So thats quite important.
I think that's one of the
lessons that you can learn from
this type of this n technology.
It's become so easy nowadays to
create powerful web
applications by meshing up a
sort of different web services
from different areas.
How do we make sure we
don't misuse that trust?
How do we make sure a Google
Wave robot does not copy
everything you put in the Wave,
and sends it off to somebody
you don't want to be able
to listen in on your wave?
How do you know?
If we have an android app, how
do youy know this android app
isn't looking at your Gmail
context address book, apps, and
whatever, and does something
that you you don't want to do?
That, you don't want, right?
Whoever reads what's in here?
It's become like a
software license.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
So, I think that's one of the
big challenges for us today.
I think the answer also lies in
the social networks themselves.
The power lies also in the
strength of the networks and
you see more and more people
and companies using this.
I know one person
who you can trust.
That's Eliza, the robot shrink.
Feel free tonight when you're
alone in your hotel room
have a chat with her.
This is her address.
That's my address.
Please come to me later if you
want to talk about Eliza,
interesting stories or if she's
helped you through
your depression.
Thank you.
BRADY FORREST: Thank
you very much.
Now we've got just two more
speakers, and in case you came
in late, everybody here is
doing Ignite talks, they are
just five minutes long. 20, 15
second slides, but the
speakers have no control
over their sides.
Have pity on them.
Our next 2 speakers are pretty
experienced, though so
I'm not worried about it.
You may know him as the
King of the Cheeseburgers.
Please welcome up Ben Huh.
BEN HUH: Hi you guys.
You may know me from such
highbrow web sites as failblog
Icanhascheezburger.com and
one of our newer sensations
verydemotival and we run about
like 50 other web sites now,
and growing on a weekly basis,
so Brady has asked me to talk
about the evolution of the
meme, pronounced meeeemmmmeee.
Which is the idea that
ideas are transmitted
from person to person.
A meme is something passed on
for one person to another.
An evolution of memes have
occurred throughout our lives
and we may not have noticed it.
And I'll tell you about the
definition and the rules of the
meme, that as we know it today
are something that anybody
can participate in.
Even this guy.
We don't actually control who
is a part of meme or not
because everybody
owns the idea.
Even that old guy, and that
busty chesty lady and that
nice, sexy legs, they can all
participate because everybody
owns what a meme is and this
is part of a communal process
in generating things.
And, I don't want you to
get confused about memes
and viral content.
Meme's are not same
thing viral content.
Viral content is a
subset of memes.
It's related in that way
where a burrito is related
to a clogged artery.
And also, it's not an
internet kind of thing.
In fact, this is not
owned by Al Gore.
Memes actually started well
before the internet, and
actually word meme came from a
book well before the internet
was ever even created.
We want to delve into
the history of this.
I started looking back and I
tried to figure out when to the
idea of virus start and it
looks like it actually started
well before civilization.
Once people try to figure out
how things worked, like they
developed a skills set they
could actually pass along to
each other and passing along a
skill from person a
person was a meme.
And, what we're trying to do
here buy buildings cities, and
figuring God, and religion
is to try and to create
order in and our world.
So this is early civilization.
Ideas of viruses were designed
to create order and structure
of how we understand the
universe and now we all know
thanks to that, you cannot
walk in the [? motor. ?]
And also, after we-- I'm
competing with my own damned
slides -- all right.
I'm just going to sit here
quietly and let you guys watch.
So, once we how the world
worked, and we thought how
do we use the world to
liberate ourselves?
How we become free of
the constraints of
our physical world?
We started to publish things.
We created a printing press.
We set scientific knowledge and
scientific methods and ideas
that can transmit
to other people.
And then we decided that
advertising would set us free.
We could create products and
sell to each other and it would
make our glory holes clean.
There was a backlash to that.
And the backlash to advertising
was internet culture.
And a lot of us here are fans
of internet culture because we
realize that internet culture
is about to chasing happiness.
That we could, in turn take
mass media turn it upside-down
and make ourselves and each
other happy because we're angry
at pop culture because
it gave us Twillight.
And if you don't notice those
two guys are the two main male
characters who are supposed to
be kissing Bella, but these
these hands had made
them kiss each.
The problem with pop culture
is it's owner oriented.
It's one way.
It's top down.
It's actually not
controlled by the masses.
It's actually controlled by the
few people who control the
medium that it works in.
But, internet culture
is different.
We can enjoy this very simple
photo, and laugh at it and get
hours of laughter out of it.
You can actually progress that
and put somebody else's face in
it, try a different animal,
photoshop it and actually
evolve the culture because
we're subverssive.
Thank you Google will for
this wonderful suggestion.
And, in fact an entire
grassroots community of people
have developed around about the
idea that you could make fun of
Google by looking at the
suggested results, and because
this is a limitless this
property that we can actually
take culture, re-appropriate it
and continue to grow an
audience people who enjoy
subverting, and sharing this
culture with another without
actually owning it.
And we have to use
our powers for good.
You can't just spam your
friends for Farmville
gifts all the time.
You have to actually think
about how your subversive
nature effects one another and
I would argue that this world
is more about making
making each other happy
than anything else.
And to make ourselves a little
bit happier, I'm going
dance on stage with Matt.
00:52:43,9 --> 00:52:43,08
[APPLAUSE]
Where the hell is Matt?
And that's the end of my
presentation and here is Matt.
MATT: OK, I realize that using
this here is a fail on many
levels but it's gonna
avert disaster.
OK, here we go.
A great circle is an imaginary
line around the earth.
It splits it into
2 equal halves.
We all know the equator, but
you can actually draw an
infinite number of them by
extending a line between
any 2 points on the globe.
Using Global Earth, I made
one that starts at Barbra
Streisand's house, and passes
through Dick Chaney's private
residence in McClain, VA.
Continue the line all the
way around and you've got
yourself a great circle.
Today, I'm going to talk
about another slightly more
substantial great circle.
I call it the imaginary line of
you ancient cosmic weirdness.
But, first a disclaimer.
This is not my own research.
I got obsessed with the great
circle website by a guy named
Jim Alison and I'm basing
my talk on his work.
To define the imaginary line in
question, I'm going to start
with 2 very well-known ancient
sites; the pyramids at Giza in
Egypt and the mysterious
Nazclines of the west
coast of of Peru.
Now that we've got our lines,
we're going to follow it around
to see what else we run into.
For over 4,000 years, the
pyramids of Giza were the
tallest structures
ever built by man.
Some believe the adjacent
sphinx is even older,
serving as a gateway to
the afterlife for some
of pre-egyptian culture.
Fitting then is that today, you
can admire it from across the
street, while consuming a deep
dish meat lover's combo.
Way out in the Sierra, the
Oasis of Siwa is believed to
have been settled around
10,000 years ago.
It was known as the Oracle of
Amon Ra in 332BC when Alexander
the Great marched 500 miles
in the wrong direction to
ask it if he was a God.
The Oracle confirmed that
he was the son of Zeus.
That has nothing to do
with imaginary lines.
It's just awesome.
Heading east, the line follows
Moses's path out of Egypt
across Israel and into Jordan
where we reach the city
Petra founded by the
Nabateaens in 500BC.
The written language that
emerged out of Petra is
known today as Arabic.
And, of course Petra is
where Indiana Jones
found the holy grail.
Crossing Saudi Arabia and into
Iraq, the line take us to the
ancient Sumerian city of Ur,
one of the oldest human
settlements in existence.
Somewhere around 2000BC, a guy
named Abraham grew up here,
before wondering west and
starting the Hebrew tribe.
All sorts of crazy stuff
happened after that.
You should Google it.
The line take us into Iran
where we find Persepolis
founded by Cyrus the Great.
Persepolis was the capital of
the vast Persian empire, until
it conquered by Alexander.
Still coasting on his Godliness
Alexander got drunk and burned
the city down on a dare.
Which is why Persians
still know him today as
Alexander the Douch.
In Pakistan we find the remains
of city of Mohinju Daro which
in 2500BC was one of the most
advanced cities in the world.
It thrived for a thousand
years until the Harappans
suddenly disappeared in an
archaeological puff of smoke.
We don't know anything else
about the Harappan people,
because no one could
read their handwriting.
The imaginary line continues in
Asia passing through ancient
cities in India, Burma,
Thailand, and Cambodia which
brings the tally up to 10 sites
that fall within its pass.
The line enters the vast blue
emptiness of South Pacific
ocean, where it crosses
directly through tiny island
2000 miles from any other
land worth mentioning.
That would be Easter Island,
home to the Rapa Nui people who
once carved 100's of massive
stone heads called Moai and
scattered them all over the
place for no good reason.
Entering South America we find
the city of Machu Picchu is a
bit too far north of the line,
with but if we go south, from
the famous Inca trail, we
quickly reach the much larger
city of Ollantaytambo, which
lies directly under
the line's path.
And finally, the last stop.
The massive line drawings
of the Nazca people.
So large that can only
be seen from the air.
They don't show a great
satellite imagery though, so
I've overlaid a clear map.
Notice how the drawings are
oriented not along the North
South polar axis but strictly
parallel to the imaginary line
of ancient cosmic weirdness.
What does this mean?
Is civilation somehow drawn
to or catalyzed by this
particular bearing?
Is the line tied to the
positions of the stars?
Are there undiscovered
cities buried in the sand
dunes of the Sahara?
And, I'll just go
ahead and say it.
Where's the lost island of
Atlantis on in all this?
Here's my best answer.
Apophenia.
The tendency to see
meaning in random data.
Human intelligence relies on
our ability to see patterns and
it's constantly delivering us
false positives which is why we
see a face on mars, find Jesus
in a potato chip, and buy
into corney theories in
horribly written novels.
There are thousands of ancient
settlements that are nowhere
near the imaginary line of
ancient cosmic weirdness.
The real link between the
places I've shown is that they
were inhabited by people with
the same compulsion to ascribe
meaning and important to random
data around in an attempt to
make some sense out of life.
That said, I want to throw
one more thing that you.
The Piri Reis Map completed in
1513 by the Turkish mariner of
the same name, drawn on the
hide of a gazelle for lack
poster board, it features an
accurate likeness of the
South American coast line.
Why is that weird?
Because by 1513, no western
explorer had mapped the
South American coast line.
Some even claimed that stretch
of land on the bottom is a
fairly accurate depiction of
the Antarctic Coast, which no
one is supposed to have
seen until the 1820's.
The map also shows the correct
distance between Africa
and South America.
Without a reliable way to
measure longitude, maps
from centuries later
still got that wrong.
In the margins, Piri mention
compiling a map from 20
different sources, some dating
back to the time of, here he is
again, Alexander, effectively
preserving knowledge from other
maps have been lost to history.
Now take a look at these two
islands the mid-atlantic.
We've got a spot on depiction
of South America and yet there
to huge phantom land masses
that we know for certain
do not exist today.
What the hell is islands?
Here's Google's earth satellite
view the area described
the Piri Reis.
Here's the map overlaid
on top of it.
Now, let's bring back the
imaginary line of the
ancient cosmic weirdness.
BAM Atlantis.
00:58:13,578 --> 00:58:13,458
Done.
Thanks for your time.
[APPLAUSE]
BRADY FORREST: Dancing's
a lot easier, isn't it?
All right.
Thank you all for coming.
I hope you enjoyed it.
These videos will be up on the
Ignite show and you should
start one in your town.
Take care.